so I remember once I auditioned for you
I shot a best week ever once and one of
the jokes I did it was right when
Current TV came out which was Al Gore's
television thing and my joke was
something to this effect that was like
oh you know Al Gore has a new TV channel
called Current TV can you imagine if
George W Bush did oh yeah Fox News not
not the most brilliant thing ever but I
could but I thought pretty solid that's
a solid joke right and I remember the
producer kind of looked at me from the
side like we're not going to be doing
that sort of thing around here and I
don't think they aired it my little that
was too political for that that was like
too political for that it's pretty mild
extremely mild but you know they were we
live in corporate culture where
everyone's afraid to offend everybody
how do you deal with that stuff no now
we can circle back to that
like when wet have you ever said I'm
sure you oh no you've gotten into some
he tried for so yeah it's like I've said
[ __ ] on Twitter that gets people upset
yeah um I'm not just talking the Nazis I
mean like a wider wider yeah
but I mean it never really like
widespread condemnation it's always
coming from the Michelle Malkin crowd
who never called me whiter than toilet
paper once or something like that this
guy's whiter than old toilet paper well
not according to the alt-right you're
not yeah I'm not even white my friend I
know big Jew mm-hmm yeah not even white
um I I am not particularly self
censorious is that the word yeah but do
you think about it ever because I do
sometimes think man like there'll be
something that I want to say like really
and even just I'll be like I got to
change this one word
yeah not because it's really what I mean
is any different but because but but
that's a badass just there's nothing
wrong with that there's nothing wrong
with making sure that what you're trying
to say is being heard in the way you
want to say it right I mean when I've
gotten in trouble on Twitter it's
generally because I've been too hasty in
terms of how I say something not really
about what
saying I have no problem with there
being consequences for people saying
stupid [ __ ] mm-hmm the the First
Amendment allows you to say whatever you
want but it doesn't protect you from the
consequences of your speech is just the
government can't right come in so you
can use your speech and then other
people can use their speech to counter
your speech it's actually a beautiful
beautiful thing and I want to be a total
[ __ ] on Twitter and say racist
horrible [ __ ] I can do that yeah um but
you know my employer might get upset
with me and I have to be I have to
understand that going in right so
there's free speech but consequences of
course there's always been consequences
to free speech yeah I I think the idea
the concept of free speech is widely
misunderstood in this country people
think they should be able to sort of uh
excrete whatever diarrhea they want from
their mouth mm-hmm and they absolutely
can but if somebody comes along and is
like I'm gonna wash your mouth out with
soap
I gotta be prepared to deal with that
right not punch you while I'm washing
your mouth out but they can use their
speech and I can throw you in jail yeah
you know it's funny when I went to UCLA
as I mentioned before with Milo and I we
just did one of these which we've done
many times before and there were all
these protesters and first they were
blocking people from coming in which you
can't do that you gotta you can protest
of course but use your do encounters
rally the next day scream all you want
all that's up but you can't throw
garbage cans and they were get getting
in cops faces I mean really there were
people with phones right and cops were
just begging to like set them off which
goes to the whole other thing we
discussed but at one point one of the
protesters came in and we started
screaming in the middle of it and I
stopped and I said look I bet you that
if you ask Milo a question right now a
direct question so we were gonna do this
at the Q&A but if you ask him saying
right now he'll answer it and she just
screamed I
and I and I was like that's the problem
here that that's my problem with what's
happening on the left it was like I
opened the door for you to make a point
make let's have that exchange of ideas
but all she could come up with was that
he and it was like that was your chance
to say no you are a whatever you want to
call them you know you mean you're a you
don't like Muslim people you know like
that about whatever you want to like
this is it I'm giving you a chance
that's a lot of cameras here but you're
five under people and that's what you
came up with and that's my problem with
a lot of what's going on on the college
is it's like these people don't even
know what they're protesting right there
they just hear something that they kind
of don't like and then they freak out
and they want safe spaces and trigger
warnings and all this other nuts well I
am uh as somebody who traffics in free
speech for a living I am cognizant of
the concern on campuses that that free
speech is being shut down and of course
I find I oppose that I oppose inviting
somebody to campus and then because some
group has an issue with that person
disinviting them right a college campus
of all places should be a place where
every point of view is heard yeah no
problem with protesting those people as
you said protest in a respectful way or
protest in a way that is lawful right
you don't have to do it respectfully you
can yeah you can you can be loud and
upset and angry and sure but um but I
agree with you I don't think you can
block the inch I mean well you can I
mean you're just gonna get arrested
that's that's on you but but I do think
the the the college campus thing has
gotten from what I read I mean I don't
know cuz I'm not experiencing it but it
feels like it's gotten very intolerant
and that's a problem they got a real
problem and the danger is that these are
our future leaders well that's what I'm
concerned thing is I don't think it's a
problem ultimately I think it's a
problem in the sense that
I think it speaks to a larger problem
but I do think people will leave those
institutions and take their place in
society and it will all be fine I'm not
I'm not concerned about it long term
particularly really I mean you don't
think like that just a generation of
these people who have been sort of
coddled into this safe space thing that
they're gonna be the 20 year olds that
are 25 you're already in for that you
know you mean that eventually they'll
have been so used to never hearing
anything that they didn't like or or
everything that they don't like is hate
speech in their eyes that they've you
know diminished the ability to do this
that that's my concern I think it's a
legitimate concern I've seen no evidence
to this point that it's going to be a
problem down the road maybe it will be
maybe it won't be I don't know I'm not
I'm not that concerned about it only
because I feel like my basic philosophy
and parenting and in life is the kids
are all right they're gonna be fine you
know just did you steal that from a
movie I did not you were thinking that
before they yes the kids are all right
yeah they'll be fine it'll all work
itself out I do think the the larger
point is this idea that victimization is
empowerment that you by claiming victim
status are thereby empowered and thereby
take the moral high ground in whatever
you do by clear on victim status that's
problematic to me so what do we do about
that because that that gets to the heart
of all of this thing everyone's trying
to figure out how they're a victim right
so that they can somehow be a little
more moral deprive everyone beneath the
problem is with very few exceptions a
lot of people can make a claim you know
they're there their claims are not
without merit whether you're black
Hispanic Muslim female gay whatever it
is you are you can make an argument like
you you have faced some problems and you
have to deal with them and there's
nothing wrong I think in asserting and
stating your case and saying this is
where I feel like society is coming up
short and dealing with us mhmmm but
there's no as you're saying there's no
there's no
no positive movement beyond that once
you've identified your grievances right
I can't wallow in them because the world
isn't going to give you anything and I
don't think the world should give you
anything we should all be treated
equally the playing field has to be
equal and maybe the playing field is in
equal well that's I think the larger
issue that playing field isn't equal and
so what's so funny about Trump is he's
elevated the white male to victim status
if he's somehow made white men into
victims and you know that's the final
frontier of hilarity right it's funny to
me too because if I make fun of Hillary
which I do all the time they love it and
it gets a zillion retweets and if I make
fun of Bernie of course they love it
I make fun to anyone and the whole time
they're telling me how much they love
free speech and I again I say this as I
understand that free speech relevation
on there nodding but then every time I
make a crumpled biloba joke and that you
you say you don't get it yet you're
banned that look they can use their free
speech to counter me but I always think
it's like I just want them to understand
like a little bit of the irony here you
know to be like guys I'm literally like
I'm not like kill the guy I'm like right
sorry it's like it's hard when you're
guys being attacked and you know in a in
a in an election season you know even as
somebody who's not like an ardent
Hillary supporter when I hear getting
attacked like my hackles go up yeah and
I'm like and and I have to check myself
like why why do you care right that's
funny because I had a I don't really
like Hillary and I don't like Trump and
I don't know what I'm a boat for Gary
Johnson I'm still not sure I'll say
something a couple weeks I guess but
like I've defended Hillary at times
because I think the attacks from a lot
of the Bernie people were totally unfair
like making it sound like she's truly
this warm on mongering neocon it's like
she's not calling for war against anyone
you know I mean I know she's made some
bad choices but Obama was the president
for a lot of those bad choices too yeah
you know Libya and whatever else and a
lot of the serious stuff but it's like
every time I defend her then people say
oh you're a Hillary supporter and then I
make a better joke about trumpet that is
a you a like it's like it's just a lot
of noise at the end of the day yeah well
that that's that's the world you're
trafficking in right now yeah the noise
world in noise three little viet world
come to my house in Connecticut yeah why
all right you are from Canada quiet yeah
yeah but the problem
though that you're a heterosexual white
man and I feel like being around that
privilege wouldn't be that great for me
for you yeah gay married dude so yeah
yeah a little better than you know what
were um we like we like a little a
little diversity up in Connecticut you
like a little woody little what do you
get you a little yeah you're not in uh
what's the really finish our you know
yeah no no diversity over there I used
to when I was doing stand-up I would do
catering gigs or out in Connecticut
there was not a I mean it was the
whitest thing yeah there was colors of
white that I had never seen before
that's how white it was yeah there
anything wrong with that
where I am is is pretty white and it's
embarrassing yeah get to the point where
like the every Sunday there's a concerts
on the green in my little town and um
you know the few black families that
live in town you know you just you just
stare at them like this I'm the most
patronizing way like I love you I love
you white guilt is something oh it's the
worst it's the worst I I there there are
there are times where I feel like I
could die from white guilt yeah I was on
a cruise ship and the waitstaff at this
dinner I don't know they're from all
over the world and at one point one of
the evenings they had to perform a song
and dance for us the waitstaff and it
was unbearable to me honestly felt like
if I could die from white guilt right
now cuz you were all white patrons more
on the ladies staring at those people
from Bangladesh going thank you for
coming
dinner tonight yeah we hope you like
your chicken or whatever they were
seeing and you're just like oh my god
yeah is are the songs about the know
that first songs were not about the food
but that would have been that would be
pretty good like a subtext of Botox like
you were eating the stuff we don't eat
you know we had a oh they give us is
lentils
we hope you like the meat I'm glad we
ended this thing out of funny note so
you see what we did there we went
serious
then we went I think there was something
funny about a trillion it's ago I
thought there was one moment of humor
about fishing bill introduced me as
comedian Michael Ian but just bear with
citizen
yeah billion black American citizen how
about depressed dar I'm not depressed
but I'm no but I'm trying to make you
give you a little Craig I mean because
if you're depressed or if you were you
had a limp or something right that way
next time you come out I'll say these
guys breasts he's limping he's you know
he the first week he was you know what
next time I'll tell them that he
couldn't fly first-class yeah yeah I did
fly first-class coming out here I know
on JetBlue on JetBlue again I think they
did as good those real nice it's real
nice it seems like extra like you don't
even need all that oh yes oh yeah well
you know what it's for it's for halfway
through the flight to come in [ __ ] jerk
you off huh meanwhile I'm doing it
myself back in coach like some kind of
schmuck
and on that note I want to thank Michael
Ian Black you can follow him on Twitter
and if you want to send him any Nazi
memes or anything like that you might
retweet you or comment on it I think
that's possible Tyler or check out
Michael Ian Black dot-com and the
thousand shows that he has in production
at the moment thanks for watching and
we'll do it again next week
you